esta vez nos preguntan cuál función
tiene un valor mayor en la intersección
con el eje james y bueno primero tenemos
aquí a fx que es igual a 2x cuadrada
menos 6 x 4 y recuerda para saber cuál
es el valor de la intersección con el
eje james lo que habrá que ver es cuánto
vale efe cuando x vale 0 es decir vamos
a buscar el valor de f de 0 déjame
escribirlo aquí vamos a buscar el valor
de f de 0 y para eso vamos a sustituir
el valor de x por 0 y me va a quedar 2
por 0 al cuadrado lo cual es 0 y después
me queda menos 6 por 0 lo cual también
es cero después me queda solamente 4 así
que
efe de 0 es igual a 4 para mi función
fx entonces cuando x vale 0 fx toman el
valor de 4 ahora vamos a comparar esta
función ftx con esta otra función
y si observas esta otra función gtx
intersecta al eje y en el valor de 3
cuando x vale 0
vale 3 entonces nos preguntan cuál
función tiene un mayor valor en la
intersección del eje y bueno pues ahora
sí podríamos decir sin dudarlo que es fx
fx es nuestra respuesta correcta es este
de aquí así que voy a quitar este
ejercicio y vamos a hacer otro ejercicio
más donde comparemos dos funciones ahora
voy a hacer este que tengo aquí y dice
cuántas raíces tienen en común las
funciones y bueno me dan la función ftx
y aquí tengo a la función gtx y si
observas la función gtx ya nos está
diciendo sus raíces sus raíces están
justo aquí menos 1 y 2 entonces habrá
que encontrar las raíces de la función f
x para ver si tienen raíces en común que
por cierto van a ser a lo más 2 porque
solamente tenemos 2 raíces en x
y bueno hay dos formas de hacer esto la
primera sería substituir los valores de
las raíces deje de x en fx a ver si
también no obtengo cero es decir ponerle
el valor de x igual a menos 1 aquí
adentro esta función para ver si también
es raíz de la función f de x o la otra
forma que se me ocurren y es la forma
que voy a usar es tratar de factorizar
esta función para así encontrar sus
raíces así que qué te parece si vamos a
hacerlo y para eso me voy a fijar en la
función f x y pensemos un poco en sus
raíces y para eso voy a factorizar es
decir voy a pensar en dos números que su
producto sean menos 6 y sumados me den
más 1 porque es el coeficiente que
tenemos aquí es este coeficiente
entonces me voy a fijar en dos números
que al sumarlos me den 1 y al
multiplicarlos medel menos 6 y bueno
observa que son de signos contrarios
porque tenemos aquí un signo negativo
entonces van a hacer
y 2 - 3 y 2 no no no espera más 3 y
menos 2 es decir esta función de aquí la
podemos escribir de la siguiente manera
la podemos escribir como x + 3 que
multiplica a x menos 2 bien entonces
esta función se va a ser cero cuando
bueno cuando x tome los siguientes
valores x tome el valor de bueno en este
caso menos 3 si x toma el valor de menos
3 esta función sea cero y aquí cuando x
toma el valor de 2 porque observa si
ponemos aquí el valor de menos 3 voy a
obtener menos 3 + 3 lo cual es cero y 0
por lo que sea me va a dar 0 entonces en
este caso mi función sería 0 y cuando x
vale 2 pasa lo mismo así que veamos
cuántas raíces tienen en común las
funciones bueno x igual a menos 3 está
por aquí por lo tanto es claro que no es
una raíz en común pero
x igual a menos 2 esta está aquí y es
así es una raíz en común por lo tanto fx
x si tienen una raíz en común la raíz en
común es x igualados
entonces me preguntan cuántas raíces
tienen en común las funciones bueno
tienen una raíz en común muy bien estas
medias pues están así que voy a quitar
todo esto y vamos a hacer el siguiente
ejercicio este que está aquí y nos
preguntan las funciones tienen la misma
concavidad y de nuevo vamos a comparar
estas dos funciones
fx y gtx pero para esto sería muy bueno
recordar qué tipos de concavidad existen
y es que hay dos tipos de concavidad o
tener una concavidad de este estilo que
es una función cóncava hacia arriba o
es una función cóncava hacia abajo así
que si observas de manera inmediata
puedes decir que head
es una función que es cóncava hacia
arriba habrá que preguntarnos si la
función fx es cóncava hacia arriba
también es cóncava hacia abajo y aquí la
clave es fijarnos en el coeficiente que
tiene x cuadrada si nos fijamos en el
coeficiente que tiene x cuadrada podemos
saber si es cóncava hacia arriba o
cóncava hacia abajo si éste es positivo
este coeficiente entonces va a ser
cóncava hacia arriba porque si nos
tomamos valores más y más y más alejados
a 0 entonces esta función que tenemos
aquí va a crecer mucho más rápido que
todos los demás términos y al
multiplicarlo por algo positivo vamos a
obtener algo que se va a ser positivo
tarde o temprano va a tomar un valor
positivo y bueno de hecho no es
alejarnos del cero es alejarnos del
vértice porque si nos fijamos en el
verde si nos vamos alejando de este
vértice y hacia la derecha oa la
izquierda entonces en este término
cuadrática que tenemos aquí nos va a ir
dando valores más
y más y más grandes y por lo tanto mi
función va a ser cóncava hacia arriba y
de manera contraria si tenemos aquí un
signo negativo si este coeficiente que
está al lado de la equis cuadrada toma
un valor negativo entonces va a pasar lo
contrario entre más nos alejemos del
vértice vamos a ir obteniendo valores
más y más grandes pero cuando los
multiplicamos por este signo negativo
entonces se van a ir haciendo cada vez
más pequeños y es por eso que tenemos
una concavidad hacia abajo porque este
término va a dominar a todos los demás
así que si observamos aquí tenemos un
signo negativo y entonces podemos decir
que esta función
fx va a ser cóncava hacia abajo lo que
quiere decir que estas dos funciones de
plano no tienen la misma concavidad no
tienen la misma concavidad y bueno ya
con esto acabamos este vídeo espero que
lo hayas encontrado interesante